>> THE NEW YORK ISLANDERS MOVED
TO THE HEART OF BROOKLYN IN
OCTOBER OF THIS YEAR.
TICKET SALES HAVE BEEN SLUGGISH.
I LOVE HAVING A PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS TEAM IN BROOKLYN.
SO I HAD CAL CLUTTERBUCK SELL
THE SPORT TO AN UNTAPPED
AUDIENCE. MY HOOD.
>> WE HAVE NHL'S CAL CLUTTERBUCK
COMING TODAY. WHAT ADVICE DO YOU
GIVE TO CLUTTERBUCK
>> I DON'T KNOW. CLUTTERBUCK?
CHANGE YOUR NAME
I DON'T KNOW.
I LIKE IT, CLUTTERBUCK
>> DID YOU GUYS KNOW THE
NEW YORK ISLANDERS HOCKEY TEAM
OWN THE STADIUM?
>> I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
HOW DO YOU GET BLACK PEOPLE
INTERESTED IN HOCKEY?
>> THE CHEERLEADERS.
GETTING IN ON THE ICE,
SKATING.
>> OH, (BLEEP)!
I LOVE IT!
THAT'S HOW YOU DO THAT!
CLUTTER BUG
THAT'S LIKE AN INSULT.
GET OUT OF HERE, YOU
CLUTTER BUG
>> CLUTTER BUCK!
OH, CLUTTER BUCK!
>> IT WON'T BE EASY.
BEFORE I GET HIM TO HELP MY
PEOPLE, THERE IS A THING OR TWO
I NEED TO LEARN ABOUT HIS WORLD.
LET ME ASK YOU, WHAT IS HOCKEY?
>> IT'S ONE OF THE COOLEST
SPORTS OUT THERE.
>> ICE IS FROZEN WATER. BLACK
PEOPLE DON'T MESS WITH WATER
HALF OF US CAN'T SWIM, YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M SAYING.
HOW DO YOU GET US TO GET
INTERESTED IN THIS?
>> YOU GET TO RUN PEOPLE THROUGH
THE LINE.
>> OH!
THOSE THINGS THERE, YOU GET
TO HIT PEOPLE INTO THAT AND
THERE'S NO CHARGES OR
NOTHING?
>> NO CHARGES.
COPS SHOW UP?
NO
YOU CAN GET IN A FIST FIGHT
AND IT'S A TIME OUT.
>> THE ONLY SPORT WHERE YOU GET
A TIME OUT!
>> YOU'RE ALREADY LOSING WITH
BLACK PEOPLE BECAUSE WE BEAT OUR
KIDS.
SHOW ME HOW YOU DO IT.
>> LET'S GO.
YOU HAVE PADS WAITING FOR YOU.
PUT YOUR SHIN PADS ON.  PRETTY
SELF-EXPLANATORY.
>> YOU'RE A SMART ASS.
DO YOU NEED ME TO DO THAT?
>>NO, I CAN DO MY LACES.
>> LAST TIME I HAD SOMEONE TIE
MY LACES I WAS EIGHT YEARS OLD
YOU KNOW WHAT?
NOT NECESSARY.
DO YOU SEE THAT?
>> OH, SERVICE NOW.
THERE YOU GO.
I'M NERVOUS.
>> SHOULD BE.
YOU'RE LIKE A DEAD MAN WALKING
NOW.
>> THAT'S WHAT I FEEL LIKE.
LET ME TELL YOU, I GREW UP IN
EAST NEW YORK IN BROOKLYN DURING
THE HEIGHT OF THE CRACK EPIDEMIC
AND THAT DOES NOT SCARE ME AS
MUCH AS THIS ICE SCARES THE
(BLEEP) OUT OF ME, Y'ALL!
>> YOU'RE THE STEREO TYPICAL
TRASH TALKER.
>> HEY!
(BLEEP)!
>> WHY ARE YOU CALLING ME THAT?
I'M NOT SAYING YOU'RE CHEATING
BECAUSE I'M BEATING YOU AT YOUR
OWN SPORT.
>> ON YOUR MARK, GET SET, GO!
HA HA HA!
I GOT 'EM!
LIKELY?
REALLY?
(BLEEP).
CAN WE GET A GOALIE?
>> DO IT.
THAT'S MY BOSS, LARRY
WILMORE.
WHY DID YOU CUT THAT PIECE I WAS
IN LAST WEEK?
OW!
OH, SORRY, LARRY!
SORRY!
WHERE'S MY STICK, LARRY?
OH!
IT'S LIKE A GUNSHOT!
OH, MY GOSH!
OH!
(BLEEP)!
NOW THAT I'VE HELD UP MY END OF
THE BARGAIN, HE HAS TO HOLD UP
HIS.
I TOOK HIM TO EAST NEW YORK TO
GET A HAIRCUT AT MY CHILDHOOD
BARBERSHOP.
I'M SORRY IT'S OVERCAST BUT THE
SUN COMES OUT HERE LAST.
♪♪
YOU'RE IN MY BARBERSHOP.
WELCOME.
>> I GET MY AIR CUTS EVERY
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
>> EVERY COUPLE OF MONTHS?
YEAH.
SEE MY MAN?
YOU SHOULDN'T TAKE IT ALL OFF.
I HEARD YOU WERE A HOCKEY FAN.
>> I BECAME A HOCKEY FAN WHEN
THE ISLANDERS MOVED TO BROOKLYN.
>> IS THAT WHEN THEY TOLD YOU WE
WERE SHOOTING HERE?
>> NO!
(LAUGHTER)
>> LOOK AT YOURSELF.
IS THAT THE CLEANEST MUZZIE
AROUND HERE?
>> WHAT'S THAT?
A MUSTACHE.
WE JUST CALL IT A MUSTACHE.
HAT DO THEY NEED FOR YOU TO
BECOME A HOCKEY FAN?
>> JUST WIN!
BROOKLYN LOVES YOU CAL. AND
LOVES THE ISLANDERS
I'D LIKE YOU TO SIGN MY SHIRT.
>> WHAT'S HIS NAME?
CAL, CAL CUCKELBUCK.
IT'S CLUTTERBUCK!
>> BROOKLYN WELCOMES YOU!